oh boy let me say good morning - morning
good morning back here is Eileen I
listened to strands ology all the time
and one of the things that I've noticed
is in your earlier clips of JD he's much
more smooth and polished and he's
definitely gotten worse oh really
JD do you notice that you're mumbling
more and more nervous I'm probably more
like I can't they right now probably
more I know I think about I think about
things more let me ask a question thank
you when you go I can't think of the
work can't you just substitute a
different word what do you take your
time what do you think the word you're
looking for is I know I just I forgot
what I said I think about what other
what just happened I'm thinking about
what other people are hearing and stuff
and that's what I worry about well how
about this then how about thinking about
what you want to say and screw the other
people I don't want to say actually
sometimes what you want to say is what
you don't want to say you short circuit
yes
so you're saying what's happening is
more and more you're self-conscious
about your celebrity and well yes you've
become self-conscious more so therefore
what Eileen is detecting is accurate
your your speech is getting worse and
worse in other words you've experienced
a backlash from things you've said so
now you're more aware of that and it
stifles you people that I know and yeah
all right so in other words I think I'm
reading between the lines here for
example when you were so open about your
sexuality all of a sudden the
old comes caving in and you don't like
the aftermath so now you're thinking
through every little thing you say we
here you go are you there's a scenario
blame you I remember thinking your
speech really took a turn for the worst
when you came on the air and you talked
about blowing your tax return on a
stripper you went through all the money
you got back from the taxes and you gave
it over to one stripper did you blow
$800 on a stripper you maniac I was very
drunk I had some tax refund money still
left over like so and I was so drunk
that I stopped caring what are you doing
man it's that I I know I know trust me
it was a long walk to the train and I
yeah you know when you got you took a
leap backward in your speech remember
when you spend $10,000 on webcam girls
10 grand dude this is over the course of
since I was 18 and what's the big deal
about it it's a live person on the other
end right yeah yes to direct them what's
your name on the website what is you
know I just say da VA that's it DAV and
a number stop it yeah it stands for the
badass what about banging a porn star
when he told us about that he
immediately went what was the position
the first time I there was like
missionary and she was on top the rumor
is you finished in her mouth yeah true
yes you have no tape people [ __ ]
asked me and they get it out of me my
poor boy all right Eileen there's the
answer all right
thanks guys love you all love you